Here is the basic algorithm for
incremental concept learning and
David has created a visual
illustration of this algorithm.
We're given an example and we're also
told whether it's a positive example or
a negative example.
If this is a positive example,
then the algorithm comes to the left
branch of this particular tree.
And it asks does the current
definition of the concept
cover this positive example?
We want to cover positive examples.
If it already covers the positive
example, we don't have to do anything.
We don't have to devise a current
definition of the concept.
On the other hand, if the current
definition of the concept does not
cover the positive example then
we must revise it in some way so
that it does, so we will generalize it.
On the other half of the tree,
if this example is not a positive
instance of the example, then
we can ask ourselves does the current
definition of the concept cover it?
If it doesn't cover it,
it shouldn't cover it.
And if it doesn't cover it,
then we don't have to do anything.
On the other hand, if the example
is a negative instance and
if current definition does cover it,
then we want to define our current
definition to rule it out.
So we'll specialize in
a current definition.
>> So, oftentimes, we see children
committing overgeneralization or
overspecialization.
So, to take an example of this,
we can imagine a child
that has a concept of a cat,
but the cat has to be black.
The child has only ever been around
black cats, so part of their definition,
part of their concept of
the cat is that cats are black.
When she goes over to
her friend's house,
Is introduced to her friend's cat,
and her friend's cat is orange.
Right now, she's told that this
is an example of a cat, but
it does not fit her current
definition of a cat so
she needs to generalize her definition
that cats can be different colors.
Similarly, we can imagine another child
that has only ever been exposed to dogs.
Thus the child's concept of a dog is
that a dog is anything that is furry,
has four legs and that we keep as a pet.
This child goes over to
the same friend's house and
is introduced to this orange cat.
And right now, that orange cat
fits his definition of a dog.
It's furry, it has four legs,
and they keep it as a pet.
But he's told that
this cat is not a dog.
So he needs to specialize his concept
of a dog to exclude this cat.
>> That's good, David.
It connects things with
our everyday lives.